i want to share with you some disturbing
data about a college education a college
degree today just to see how you react
to it did you know the average price of
a house in 1980 was 64 000
and it's 336 000 that is an uptick of
425 percent did you know the average
price of a car in 1980 was 7 grand today
it's 47 000
that's an increase of
571 percent but did you know the average
cost of college from 1980 till today has
increased ready
1200 percent by the way inflation from
1980 till today is 236 percent cost of
college tuition 12 hundred percent let
me get this straight incomes only 217
220 tuition for college is 1200
a thousand percent more how can the
average american afford to send their
kids to college or the student to pay
for it we're going to talk about that
today
okay so before you get upset at the
college you went to or you're going to
right now let's ask a few questions to
see if it's really worth it and then
let's make a decision but if you get
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe and share it with others
five things we're gonna talk about in
this video number one the cost increase
number two is the actual investment
meaning the four to five years and the
money you spent into it is the rate of
return worth it roll college plays does
it carry the same weight before and how
will it be disrupted what's gonna happen
to the future of college if they keep
going the way they're going today so
let's get right into it okay so today's
sponsor to the video is udemy and if you
don't know about udemy udemy is the
largest online education technology
platform in the world they have 40
million students they have 70 000
instructors 157 000 courses in 65
languages and 80 percent of fortune 100
companies use udemy to upskill their
employees and me myself there's three
courses i want to recommend to you they
got an online mba course if you've never
take i highly recommend it there's an
online programming for kids that my kids
are going through it and last but not
least they have a great course for
digital media if you're a sales person
and you don't know a lot about digital
media if you're running a business i
highly recommend you taking those
courses yourself and being part of
valuetainment you get a discount so
either click on the link above or below
to go to udemy and take one of those
three courses or search any other
courses you'd like to take so let me
explain to my concern from a perspective
being in the insurance industry in the
financial industry 20 plus years and my
agents would come up to me and say this
client here patrick wants a 2 million
insurance policy will this insurance
company underwrite it the first thing i
always said is would you underwrite this
client with your own two million dollars
and risk that and they would say i don't
know i said tell me why well the person
62 years old they smoked two packs a day
mom died at 68. dad died that's 65 65.
he's out of shape he's 320 pounds but
he's got the money to buy it i said
would you give them 2 million dollars
and allow them to buy for me says i
probably wouldn't do that so why would
the insurance company do it well let's
just see if they're going to do it or
not so you can submit it but i don't
think they're going to underwrite it
right pat what are you saying what's
your point here's my point
so
if college is so great and it's so worth
paying the 30 40 50 000 per year why
don't private banks finance it
why is most of the financing being done
by the government and why isn't the
government uh preventing these colleges
from increasing the price of every year
college increases their tuition the
government's like yeah we'll finance it
yeah we'll finance it yeah we'll finance
it and then when a kid who's 23 now and
wants to follow bk or 28 now
they'll be able to bk their credit card
debt their car loan all this other stuff
but you're not able to bk your college
loan how why not who created that law
what the government did how because
colleges
and government are officially in bed
together for every dollar that they loan
out tuition goes up 60 cents for every
dollar so universities are like oh my
gosh loan more because i can increase my
tuition loan more because i can increase
my tuition and these politicians are
confused a hell out of people in america
talking about how private corporations
are not paying enough taxes and all this
other
really wait till you see how much these
colleges have in their endowments in
their checking accounts and on top of
that the fact that they pay zero
in taxes and they have zero regulation
on how much they can increase their
prices so maybe you ought to ask your
politician in your community if you're
so worried about protecting these
medicines that takes five cents to make
and they're selling you for a hundred
bucks how come you're not going out to
college in colorado colleges and
universities for charging as much as
they do for 18 year old kids to go into
debt that they cannot afford that they
have to pay 20 years to pay off why
don't we go hold some of these colleges
accountable for paying this much in
taxes
march madness you got football games
this much in taxes yet let's distract
them and focus on these corporations
that are creating jobs and oh my gosh
they're not paying any taxes which
they're paying billions on top of
billions in taxes i think it's a fair
question to ask so so now somebody said
well pat that's not fair the way you're
talking about is the fact that college
is all they do is they sit on cash maybe
they do let's look at their dollar
amount here are 10 universities
that have a minimum of 10 billion
dollars or higher in their endowment
account which is kind of like cash and
i'm going to compare how much cash they
got versus some corporations and i want
to kind of get your reaction to see if
you're okay with that let's go through
it top 13 cornell university over 10
billion vanderbilt over 10 billion emory
university 11 billion washington
university in saint louis over 14
billion colombia over 14 billion
northwestern university over 14 billion
university university of notre dame or
over 18 billion university of penn over
20 billion mit 27 princeton 37 stanford
37 billion yale 42 billion harvard ready
53 billion now let's compare them to
some corporations and again i really
want to see your reaction comment below
if this gets you thinking and saying how
the hell is this even possible give it a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel ready
watch this you ever heard of a company
called mcdonald's you know how much you
got in cash these greedy people
2.3 billion dollars
you ever heard of starbucks massive 420
000 employees
you know how much you got in cash
3.8 billion
you ever heard of this company called
disney you know walt disney how much i
got in cash 16 billion you ever heard of
tesla this company tesla ran by this
greedy guy you know how much they got in
cash
18 billion
ford 36 billion coca-cola 36 billion
pfizer 51 billion even meta facebook
has 54 billion only one billion dollars
more than harvard are you okay with that
and we're
so hardcore on these guys not paying any
taxes yet colleges and universities they
literally pay zero taxes okay and they
have the same amount of cash if not more
by all these other corporations that are
day-to-day competing they have to
compete every day
hiring firing enemies competition
regulation
and universities regulation hey keep
funding it guys because the federal
government's financing all the loans
don't worry about it it's all going to
be all right are you okay with that does
it make you think the way it makes me
think all right so now that you've got
your blood flowing and you're kind of
sitting out there saying i have no clue
this type of stuff is taking place let's
talk about average starting salary when
you go to college a kid goes to college
i'm willing to do everything you told me
counselor i'll increase a-c-t s-a-t i'll
take the honor i'll take this i'll take
everything you say because i want to get
in because you promise me when i get out
i'm going to get a fat salary do you
know the average expectation
of a college grad when they come out is
to make a hundred four thousand dollars
but you know what the average college
grad comes it makes when they come out
fifty five thousand dollars by the way
do you know the average uh computer
science graduate that comes out they're
expecting to make 95 000 they're a
little bit more realistic and their
average salary 75 000
watch this one the ones that are the one
that think they should make the most
money and they make the lease
journalists get out of college thinking
they should make a hundred and seven
thousand dollars you know what's the
average journalist salary when they get
out of college after they went to
colombia and spent a couple hundred
thousand dollars
forty five thousand dollars that's the
starting salary let me give you some
starting salaries you ought to be
thinking about humanities fifty thousand
dollars communications 55 agriculture 57
business 60 social science 61 math and
sciences 67 engineering 74 computer
science 76 do you get the idea you want
me to spend 200 000 to come out and
compete in the marketplace after giving
you 45 years of my life and i'm only
making this kind of money was it really
worth me spending the dollar there maybe
it is maybe there's other things that
we're not even talking about which we
will hear in a minute
so let's talk about evolution of
education and why it was needed and how
companies are going away from requiring
four-year degrees and i'll actually give
you some specific data but here's what
happened over the years so we first
started off with age of manufacturing in
the 1900s this is when companies like
ford boeing rca came out and companies
started saying look man we need people
to be a little bit more educated okay
great universities are like hey we'll
offer this we'll offer that and so
companies said it's better if we hire
people that are going to college so
college was actually valuable because it
was teaching things that you need to
know at that time then we went to age of
distribution this is when walmart came
in toyota procter and gamble ups so they
started saying look we definitely need
this is getting global business is
changing we need some people to start
having a little bit more experience
college is definitely more necessary
then then in 1990 age of information
showed up and google yahoo comcast
facebook and the idea of memorizing
stuff when you went to school was no
longer valuable google screwed
everything up when it came down to
memorization because nobody the only
like how much does an average guy on
jeopardy make for memorizing all the
stuff that they do tell me a billion are
on jeopardy
what a great memory you got it means
nothing because i can answer it faster
than you based on google a hundred
percent of people in the world are
smarter than the smartest guy on
jeopardy because they got google in
their hands let me say that one more
time 100 the average person in the world
is smarter than the smartest person on
jeopardy because they got google game
over so if you want jeopardy 28 years
ago nobody cares today because the
average seven-year-old can beat you
because they got access to google
youtube if i want to learn how to do
something yes 40 years ago holy [ __ ] i
gotta go find somebody who knows what
they're doing
today
youtube just get on there you'll learn
how to do everything you wanna do pretty
much everything you can learn how to do
on youtube those two changed the game
for education and people started
actually asking is it still worth it
then we went to age of customer which is
today uber airbnb airbnb amazon netflix
apple so some of these corporations sat
there and said wait a minute is it that
important for us to send kids
to college and only focus on recruiting
college kids so look what happened to
some of these companies
from 2017 to 2021
orange shows how many of the people they
were hiring had four-year degrees red
shows how many it is today so 2017 is
orange 2021 is today intel is requiring
more people to have four-year degrees
today when they hire them but look at
google google cares less about a
four-year degree today apple definitely
cares less facebook is a little bit less
microsoft is less accenture is less and
ibm is about the same as it was before
so what's the moral of the story here
corporations are sitting there saying
yeah we used to require for you to have
a four year degree we don't require like
like we did before because there's many
other ways to get the education and the
training they used to get only through
colleges so top 10 companies that no
longer require a four-year degree you
ready google apple bank of america tesla
netflix ibm penguin random house costco
starbucks chipotle no longer sit there
and say we need a college degree like we
did before so let's keep going as
somebody mr pat i still think colleges
are worth it so let's talk about five
reasons why people go to college and why
you know it's necessary for us to go
what is the real reason we go to college
number one the actual education we get
right we're like i'm gonna go to it's
the actual education i get fine ask the
average person that went to college what
they learned what percentage of what
they learned they can recite today four
years you went to college what can you
recite from what you learned in college
tell me they'll sit there and say well i
learned about this i learned about that
i learned about this
fine a lot of it is memorization because
our educational system is still based a
lot on memorization
and finnish finland university is being
known right now it's one of the best
education in the world they don't grade
you on memorization they grade you on
actual processing because today like i
said earlier nobody cares how smart you
are to memorize because google's a great
equalizer they want to know how you
process issues how you make decisions
watching how things are being done
visually that's the direction some
universities some countries are going to
and some in america are staying the same
way which is memorization you better
know the answers to these questions
because you got 92 percent does that
really apply in the day-to-day stuff i
took so many tests in my life ask me
what i remember from these tests i like
problem solving that's what helps right
and that's what a lot of us do need but
the actual education part you can go on
udemy and take a lot of those courses
for a fraction of the cost you spend at
university so the cost comparison to
what the actual education is there's
plenty of competition for it elsewhere
number two degree diploma the label to
be able to say
i actually got this degree from this
university fine maybe for pride maybe
for family went there you know some
parent when their mom went there that
one we got four generations of people
that went to stanford i totally respect
generation and you know rituals i
totally respect all of that fine do that
part but to be able to say the diploma
how many people sit there and say can i
see your actual diploma on what you got
certifications plenty of different
things that you can do nowadays to get
that but the diploma may be one of them
the third one would be the network
matter of fact i think the network is
actually the most valuable when you go
there you're gonna meet people that part
no matter what people say just go watch
the movie social network they sat there
they met all these guys and they were
able to recruit from each other and
build a company together that's a strong
network that one part i give high value
if you go to the right place to build
the right networks but again at the same
time you can spend ten thousand dollars
and go to the right business conference
spend a week there and still build a lot
of strong relationships at a great
business conference in europe here many
different places that you can find those
types of things number four safety it's
the safety of if it doesn't work out i
got a backup plan anybody that did
anything big in life that you and i read
about their mindset isn't a backup plan
their mindset is i'm going to go out
there and go all in and make this thing
work so the backup plan is for those
that are wanting to play it safe you may
want to change that mindset our entire
system is built on getting people to
think safe and the entire system of big
companies it is built by people that
weren't worried about that so which one
do you want to be that's a decision more
for you to make not for me to make and
last but not least freedom independence
hey i can go out there make as much
money as i want to make and do all the
stuff that i want to do fine you just
saw the numbers were you impressed by
the average salary of people coming up
you may want to rethink this part about
these five benefits that we always talk
about when we go to college you know
it's one of the worst things that
happened to universities in america
covid covet exposed everything here's
why when covet happened universities
being the most responsible institutions
out there they shut down and they
started doing everything with schooling
through zoom now harvard came out and
they asked the question they said listen
harvard since i'm coming home and i'm
not coming to the school and everything
is based on zoom can you give us a
discount and harvard said nope the stamp
of approval when you get a degree from
harvard is very valuable and because of
that you have to pay this much money
perfect that got some people to think
and say wait a minute aren't one of the
five benefits of going to harvard in the
institution is to network with other
people and spend time with them yes what
happened to that
wiped out the biggest value of going to
these universities is the people you
network with it's officially gone and
they still wanted you to pay full price
no discount even though covet was going
on which got people thinking let me get
this straight
if we are going to school at home on
zoom why do i need to go to a school in
the first place it got people saying
maybe it's a big opportunity for us to
disrupt the educational industry as a
whole and come out with online courses
maybe we start and everybody started
innovating a bunch of people started
innovating and it exposed another major
league in universities when kova took
place knowing anybody and everybody can
get educated not necessarily needing to
go to schools because i miss out on the
opportunities of networking if i still
have to pay full price i'm gonna go
elsewhere to get it done so at this
point again we've covered a lot of
different things but i want you to focus
on one thing do you remember the five
benefits we talked about earlier about
going to college education being one of
them and then we talked about the degree
the diploma the network safety freedom
and independence well let's go through
each one of them education today you can
get anywhere udemy online courses
youtube in regards to the diploma we
know it means nothing today why be
because the actual education with the
speed of innovation
they can't move at the speed of
innovation their curriculum is behind
five ten years and it's constantly
catching up and we're moving faster so
that's out the window you need to learn
courses like imagine like reading a
social media textbook from nine years
ago would it make any sense that's how
many of these universities have their
textbooks and they can't catch up with
the changes number three network you're
doing covid how we gonna network you can
network anywhere you go
number four was uh safety the fact that
you have a plan b if you want to live
life with a plan b
you're probably gonna be you know
missing out on a lot of big
opportunities for yourself and last but
not least is being away from family and
hey i kind of want my own independence
you can do that and go travel in europe
get a job and live there for yourself
and learn about different cultures you
can do that so at this point of the game
you may be thinking pat you must be 100
against college not at all if you're
doing stem science technology
engineering mathematics you got to go if
you want to be a doctor you got to go to
college i want you to go to school to
know what you're doing when you're
working on me or my family right as well
as law if that's what you want to do
it's a niche it does make sense to go
there this is not 100 against it this is
accountability for colleges for you to
start asking a question saying why are
you charging this much
if it was this much i could justify
sending my kids but my income hasn't
increased that much in the last 42 years
why are you increasing that 1200 percent
when my income's only increased at 217
that's what i want you to be thinking
about and then at the same time you have
to say well listen i can't afford to
send them they're great you got to make
some choices so here's seven
alternatives for you instead of going to
college one of them is vocational
education and trade schools there's a
lot of places you can go to learn trades
that's paying very well 50 75 100 000
your income plumbing you know there's
coding there is you know there's a lot
of different trade schools you can go to
number two is shadowing go shadow
somebody you respect in your community
that's doing very good in an industry
that you're considering watch how he or
she works watch how they negotiate watch
how they are on a daily basis at the
office in war whatever they're doing
shadow and be number two number three
entrepreneurship start a business with a
couple your friends you may fail it may
not work out you may end up losing ten
twenty thousand dollars it's a lot
better than losing two hundred thousand
dollars and i guarantee you one thing
when you do start a business you will
learn more starting a business in six
twelve months then you will go into
school for four years because there's
things that happen in business that no
four-year degree is going to teach you
next is online courses or free classes
on youtube there's plenty of content on
youtube a guy asked me a question the
other day says pat for the last eight
years all i've done is watch all the
how-to's on valuetainment and i have a
notebook he showed me his notebook every
single how-to video we've ever shot up
he had taken notes he says this has
helped me get his business was doing 11
million a year he went from zero to 11
million here says just simply following
the content here and it's free online
courses udemy plenty of courses to get
toron what to do for yourself next
military yeah i was just telling uh uh
eric here who was in the marines before
i would not be the person i am today
without the military in the military's
when i learn how to work 80 hours a week
team crisis management all of that
because that's what the military is all
about especially for some of you that
are undecided you're going to have the
time of your life you're going to travel
you're going to get your butt kicked
someone's going to challenge you
non-stop you're going to come back being
in better shape and you will be able to
handle teams and pressure that's what
military provides you and a couple last
ones work your way up go to a company
work from the bottom bring value keep
improving be willing to be challenged
and constantly improve your game and
eventually be able to work your way up
in the company
and last but not least online college
these universities many of them are now
having to teach online courses online
colleges and it's a quarter of the cost
many great universities are coming out
and they're offering this if you can't
afford or don't want to pay the 150 200
250 000 to some of these schools go find
plenty of online colleges that will help
you take courses and classes at a
fraction of a cost so if this video got
you thinking and you're sitting here
saying my gosh i want to watch this
again i want my son to watch and my mom
to watch my dad to watch and my peers to
watch i want my professor to watch it
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel and comment below some of your
ideas and if you want to get today's pdf
click here of all the notes and last but
not least i did a video titled 15 things
colleges won't teach you if you've never
seen that click here to watch that video
take care everybody bye
[Music]